en busca de la vacuna contra el cubit
con un panorama nacional de escasez de
medicamentos recesión económica y mala
gestión de los hospitales públicos
muchos venezolanos ven la oportunidad de
inmunizarse en colombia pues este país
cuenta con un mayor acceso a vacunas
europeas y norteamericanas todas
aprobadas por la oim s exactamente
colombia abrió sus fronteras para
proporcionar vacunas a los no residentes
desde el 25 de octubre en norte de
santander el estado en donde se
encuentra el principal paso fronterizo
entre ambos países más de 34 mil
personas se han vacunado contra el
coronavirus y tengo seis meses de
trabajo una venta de comida rape y
permiso hoy por
la obligación es mi deber como ser
humano y cuidarme para cuidar a los míos
venezuela con 28 millones de habitantes
ha importado vacunas de china rusia y la
más reciente de cuba sin embargo cuenta
con una de las tasas de vacunación más
bajas de américa latina con tan sólo un
32 por ciento de su población inmunizada
el número de venezolanos que cruzan la
frontera para vacunarse ha aumentado
desde el 3 de noviembre cuando colombia
abrió la vacunación para todos los niños
mayores de 3 años desde entonces se
registran 9 mil vacunas aplicadas
diariamente según las autoridades
colombianas